hey guys I'm really excited because I'm
about to build this Lego set it is the
double-decker couch it also comes with
pretty much some of the best minifigures
that I've ever seen included in any of
the lego movie sets I actually tried to
make the ghost myself by ordering one of
the old school goes doesn't quite fit
previously you were only able to get the
double-decker couch in the hold on I'm
going upstairs
in in the metal beards c-cal set which I
actually have not had time to even put
together it's really disappointing
oh my gosh this set up so you it is by
far probably one of my favorite sets
from all the lego movie ones thank you
guys for watching I hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did I have
a small little favor to ask of you
please go and click the link in the
description that will take you to a lego
ideas site there you will click support
sign up and support this project because
it needs 10,000 signatures to actually
go into production and I really want
this set to be actually a reality if you
guys do it
make sure you tweet me or Facebook me
your approve and I'll write back to you
guys
that's it I'll see you later happy
building